interesting cast Robert De Niro Marlon
Brando it was Marlon weird on this film
or was it Marley's just funny he's just
a funny funny guy he had to say to Bob
you know well you know what would you
say to four million dollars and take
after take he kept saying you know four
million Tomatoes four million apples and
finally someone said Marley can you just
save four million dollars you know
we were going to shoot this scene you
know Marlon's sitting there and Bob's
sitting there and I'm sitting on a
little couch we start and Marlon has
this bottle of um of Aqua mineral you
know like and he's talking to Bob and he
starts pouring and he misses his glass
completely and he and he starts pouring
the water all down his front which I
realize he's not perceiving I turn you
know look at Bob to see if he's picking
up on this and Bob's going
they call cut and Bob kind of Bob kind
of goes
and he looks he looks over at me and he
goes he goes
was I sleeping
I said yeah I said yeah he goes he goes